(indie rock music)
- [Boyd] Yo, I'm excited that everyone's
finally able to meet,
Yeah, so, is everyone in the room?
- Everyone's in the room.
- [Boyd] Alright, cool, hell yeah.
There's a few things, straight off the bat
that I think Gary, and
Anik should talk about,
like growing up, immigrant community,
similar to you, Gary, you know,
one bedroom, a lot of
people sharing that room
like, there's a lot of similarities.
- Bangladesh, right?
- Yeah.
- [Boyd] That you guys
could maybe build off of,
and then also, like, the music
so, the Kites project, he's
really telling his story
like, talking about Queens, New York,
but also like, he has
his sister on the intro,
and takes you to the borough,
and really telling his story
and it's such an important
time for the immigrant story
in general, just with
what's going on with America
so, it's like, he's really
shaped it up to have this,
he already has a good following,
but it's really looking
like it might go crazy,
and then the other thing
that I think is real interesting, is
he did an interview with Beats 1 recently,
and one of the things he said, was
for a while, he was
looking at himself like
looking at the goal as if
it was a kite, or whatever
like Madison Square Garden is the goal,
but then you started to
look at it more as like,
who's helped steering that kite
so it's almost like reverse engineering,
and now he's focusing more on, like
the people who are burning
up there and getting up there
and his space, and his communities,
so I thought that was pretty cool,
and along the lines of a lot
of stuff you're talking about
so I'm excited you guys
are meeting right now.
- Thanks Boyd.
Well it's awesome to meet
you guys, real pleasure.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, for sure, so, you know
talking about reverse engineering
like, knowing that you
have a little context,
I think what's most
always interesting to me,
and I know that you guys have a sense that
Boyd and I are meeting
with a lot of artists, and
it's really a very simple
model, I just basically
trust Boyd implicitly,
and then it becomes a game
of, like, how do I bring
disproportionate value?
And then the chips fall,
karma is practical, right?
That's really kind of how I think about it
and so, would love to know,
in the short term or long term
if there's anything I could help with,
and answer anything that
might be on your mind.
And that's kind of like, it's
really quite simple, for me.
Like, I just feel like, obviously, music,
and specifically hip hop music,
is so culturally important
to me, and so I associate
with it, because, whether it's
India, or Russia, or in the
African-American communities,
it's all the same story
of the rising up, right?
And so, would love to know if
there's anything that pops,
you know, especially if
you have that much context,
I mean like, anything I can help with, or,
I'd love to know a little
bit more about the story,
how it's going and the state of the union,
of where we're at right now.
- Yeah, absolutely, so,
obviously, I make music
and I've been, I've recently
dropped the project Kites
and like Boyd was saying,
it's like a perspective,
an aerial perspective of
what's important to me now
- And how many projects have you dropped?
- Two.
- Yeah.
- [Kaz] This is your first full length.
- Yeah, this is my first full length.
The first one was called
"I Don't Know Yet",
and I was going through,
like, a lot of industry shit
and it was called "I Don't Know
Yet" because I didn't really
- Because you didn't know yet!
- Yes, exactly.
So I don't really consider
that my first offer.
- It's a good name for a first project.
(laughing)
- Yeah, thanks.
- And when was that?
- That was in 2015 I believe.
- It was a mix tape?
- Yeah.
- And how many songs?
- Like, seven.
- I have a lot of traveling this week,
so I'm gonna listen to
everything, this week.
Okay, go ahead.
- Download Kites
- I will.
But you know what's funny, like, I get it,
and like, I think about
my books, or my talks,
there's still so much good
stuff in the first, you know?
First of all, the first
thing with me, with hip hop
is, I don't actually think I really
understand music very well,
the reason I think I resonate
so much with hip hop, is
I only care about the
words, almost saying like,
poem, and like, reading mentality,
to me, the artists I most associate with,
there's nothing to do with
beats, or the hook, nothing.
It's 100% the words, the
analogies, or just like,
clever cultural references
that make me laugh, you know?
I still think I love 21
Savage because he mentioned
Randy "The Macho Man" Savage,
I'm not even sure there was anything else!
- What are you listening to now?
- You know, I'm listening
to a lot of, I mean
so what's funny about the way I listen,
so I listen to a lot of older
Nas right now, weirdly enough
- Talk that shit, Gary, dog.
- Yeah, it's super interesting,
Boyd's feeding me a lot of good stuff,
like, a lot of female vocalists
are super interesting to me
and then, like, you know,
Cardi, I like seeing why,
I love analyzing why, right?
Like, to me, I'm really
good at reverse engineering,
so like, watching, whether it's
what Coach K's trying
to do with his artists,
and like, will it work, and what happens?
I grew up when P Diddy was like,
okay, now it's Mase, right, now it's this
and trying to figure
out, even when you have,
so, I have all the marketing leverage,
when I lose or win 20 years from now,
there's a reason why, even
when you have all the leverage
certain artists don't win.
- Right.
- Right?
You can put em' on, they can
show up on every right track,
you can put $20,000,000 behind them,
they could be in RapCaviar,
why don't they win?
So, a lot of what I do with music
is more of, like, trying to figure out why
things organically win, when
can you make something win,
when it wouldn't have won without you,
and why you lose when the machine tried
to put everything behind you.
- [Kaz] Well you should talk about how
you had like, offers, for record labels,
when you had "I Don't Know Yet", right?
- Yeah, no, it was
definitely before like, I had
- Before we do that, who
is everybody in the crew?
You're the artist, that I understand.
- Kaz, publicist slash branding agent.
- And how did you guys connect?
- Oh, so that's where kind
of like, we had sparring wars
me and Dominic, the manager,
I said, I tweeted at Amik
after I saw him live, because
that's when he won me over.
I kinda heard about him as,
like this singer that was like,
- But what do you do?
- I'm a publicist, so I
do a lot of the features,
oh, I'm a music publicist, yeah.
- [Gary] Understood.
So you're living your life,
you've heard a little bit
you see him live, you're like,
now I believe, and hit him up
- Yeah, I tweeted at him,
and then we connected
and it took a couple of meetings,
and we finally started to work together.
- Understood, okay.
- So I co-manage Anik, and I
heard his song two years ago
before the first project
"I Don't Know Yet",
- Just on SoundCloud, or Spotify?
- Just on SoundCloud, and
immediately, you know, I realized,
- Connected.
- Yes, exactly.
- And you had aspirations
to manage at this point?
- Yes.
- Did you manage anybody at this point?
No, I was,
- But it was in the back of your mind?
- Yeah, it was in the back
of my mind, and I knew
I wanted to work with him
specifically, because he was,
- But before you heard that song,
you're sitting in your room, in your life,
you'd thought about managing artists?
- Yeah, I was involved, I've known Mike
through college radio, I did radio at NYU,
and then I was a writer
for different publications,
and stuff like that,
- Around hip hop?
- Yeah, yes,
it was like, Complex, and stuff like that.
- Understood, so you co-manage?
- [Boyd] Yeah, so like, Darnik
kind of like, for a while
he was kind of like, a young whizz kid
in New York hip hop scene, a little bit,
and Amanda, actually,
I've been wanting you to
meet Amanda for a while,
and I think, I don't know
if she's still doing this
but she was involved in similar things,
like what Vayner would do,
like with brands and marketing
and stuff like that, too.
- Understood.
- Our story's kind of
funny, so, I used to rap,
and that's how we met, and I
actually connected them, too
and I was like, yo, I need to speak,
I run a digital agency
now, but I worked with Anik
on a whole bunch of stuff,
- I love it.
- But, yeah, so we've all kind of been,
- What's the name of your company?
- Green Room Creative.
- Awesome, man.
Good for you.
- But you know, I follow
things religiously, that you do
but also, with this guy, getting
him to be social on social
and really leveraging the narrative,
is what we've been working on.
The team's strong, we know that,
it's just about getting to the next level.
- Awesome.
- Yeah man, I guess, oh, this is Amanda.
- Hi Amanda,
- Hi, sorry,
- How are you?
- Uber driver hell.
- How are you, nice to meet you.
- I'm Amanda, nice to meet you.
- It's a pleasure.
Here, take this.
- Are you sure?
- I'm positive.
- I can stand.
Nope, it's not how we do it.
Okay, understood.
Okay, let's go back to it now.
- Yeah, so Kites is, obviously,
it's like the aerial perspective
of who I think I am now,
- How old are you?
- I'm 28, about to be 29.
- You look great, fuck!
(laughing)
- So, you know, before
I used to think like,
what's the biggest thing I
want, so I know Madison Square
and all of this stuff,
right, and like, it was up,
completely focused on the kite
- Of course.
- Now, what's more important to me,
are the people steering
it, and the people, like,
waiting to be there when
I fall, so, you know,
pull me back up,
- Of course.
- And it's kind of like,
a soundtrack to Queens
from like, Queens Plaza
to Jamaica Ave, right?
And everything in between,
and that's kind of like
what I've just recently released,
- When did it come out?
- In April.
- Have we met before?
- I don't believe so, actually
- Okay, cool, just the
way your face turned,
I was like, wait a minute, we
did meet, but okay, no worries
- And then a few months later
I had my first ever live show
which was wild.
- Where was that?
- Rough Trade, Brooklyn.
First of all, I've never had a show,
like I've never,
- I get it.
- Done a show, headliner, it
was an opener, we sold out,
- How many peeps'?
- 250, the capacity of the
room was sold the day before,
- Awesome, crazy right?
- Yeah.
- It was over capacity.
- Well, it was over, it was
only one of us four in there,
he tryina', look, I'm
gonna take all my luggage
(laughing)
- There was a 90 person guest
list on top of 200 visitors.
- That's really cool.
- Three, bro.
There was the Nun with
the top thing, anyway.
- It felt great?
- Yeah, man
it was wild, it was like,
I've never seen people
recite my music like that,
- Right,
- And I don't fuck up on stage
But day I fucked up.
- Because you were just blown away by it?
Your mind started veering
into that, I get it.
- I was like, you guys
know all of the songs, why?
- I get it.
- I didn't understand
- I understand.
- And right after I went
on my first national tour
with Jidenna, he was kind enough
to put me in there with him
and that was a really dope experience,
and I've been back for a
couple of weeks, and I'm like,
bout' to put out some
merch, I got some for you,
I partnered with three
businesses in Queens that I think
make the flavors of my
music, and basically, like
this African Halal food cart,
that's also Middle-Eastern
which is kind of like, that flavor,
also this West Indian
restaurant called Trinciti Roti,
which is kind of like West
Indian and South Asian flavors
that I have in my music, and
then just the hood Chinese spot
Fatima's Chinese
- I love it.
- And it's like, all three of those,
and I got their menus on the front,
and then shit in the back, but they're,
I got way too much, like you
know when you go to those
hole-in-the-walls, and I was like, yeah,
I don't like merch that
much, cause' I don't,
like, I wear plain stuff,
and I don't wear stuff
with like, stuff on it, it's like,
but, what would I wear, because
if I'm gonna make merch,
I gotta,
- 100%.
- You know, so I was like,
just eating at Trinciti,
and I was like, yo,
that shirt is fire, like
you know those kind of like, corny ass,
their address, big as shit on the back,
with the,
- The phone number.
- The fuckin' phone number, everything!
And I'm like, that's my
merch, that's fuckin' genius!
- That's cool, I like it.
- And I partnered with them,
but just made it more like,
you know kind of like my style,
and we kind of played
on "Made In Bangladesh",
because, all them motherfuckers that go,
and take advantage of my people,
- Of course.
- Doing all this shit, like,
I actually custom tailored these
every single piece in Bangladesh,
you know, with the lines
with my boy Feekz, who manufactured them,
and, there's like, a lot
of layers to everything
that I essentially put
out, cause', you know
Bangladesh hasn't really
been represented in this,
- Environment.
- At all.
- Yeah, at all, that's really cool.
- What's your story?
Boyd's been dying for us to connect.
- Has he?
- Yes.
- Aw! (laughing)
You know how I met Boyd?
My brother was working for Society,
that clothing brand that
was really big for a while
my brother's two years younger than me,
and Boyd was helping them with stuff,
and we literally, I was with the owner,
this dude Brendon, and my
brother, driving around Queens,
picking up merch for, like,
we needed sample stuff
and he had some of it,
and he like walked in,
like, stopped by his house,
he walked up to the car
and we connected, and never
spoke for like two years,
and we ran into each other,
something like, "Oh!"
and since then we've just been like,
trying to make all things connect
where we can for each
other, it's really random
my brother works in real
estate and insurance now.
- I love it.
Is that how you saw it, Boyd?
- [Boyd] Yeah, I had in
it on mute, but yeah,
it's been pretty epic.
- [Amanda] And that's where
we met, right, in a car?
- [Boyd] Yeah, I think I
jumped in the car, didn't I?
- [Amanda] Yeah, that sounds about right.
- [Boyd] I'm always riding down the street
and jumping in cars.
(laughing)
- It's been working out.
Well, what can I answer, if anything?
Anybody have any questions?
- Yeah, like, obviously
you're really good at looking
at things from short term,
then also looking at things from long term
and I guess, like
- Long term's super easy my man.
- Yeah?
- It just comes down to
one very, very simple thing,
legacy versus currency.
It's that basic.
- Okay.
- You're just making decisions
on an every day basis
about two things, the kite,
up and down to Boyd's part
the only reason, I think,
I'm a little bit different
than people that are
understanding it, is because
I have an unbelievable weird relationship
with money and stuff, which
is, I don't like them.
I don't know what else to say.
Every decision I make, is
predicated on my legacy.
All of them.
I've never made a decision
for money, my entire life.
Even when I didn't have it.
Even, like, I needed enough
to have rent, and stuff
but it's never been the
driver, because I think
it comes down to something
that I've been trying to unpack myself,
I think the reason that's
true, is because I think
I'm gonna end up being all-time.
I just don't think I need it, and I think
every time I take it,
it just slows it down.
So here's what I mean by that.
If you're thinking super-duper
long time, and long term,
well then, when you look at
who you surround yourself with
what shows you're gonna
do, what merch you put out,
what's your next song's title,
what project you're doing,
who you're fucking with,
what meetings you're taking,
who you marry, how you roll,
you look at it in one
perspective, which is,
when I'm 87, how the fuck
am I gonna feel about this?
And if you're that in tune with yourself,
and I don't know if everybody is or isn't,
I can't speak to that, but
I can give you the answer
to why I've gotten here, and
how I've gone about doing it
which is, it's all long-term.
Boyd's long term, for me.
And I've poured a lot of
dollars, and energy, and efforts
into different fuckin' cockamanian things
that Boyd and I have come up with,
it's not like he's my
child, Boyd and I, like
because I always knew how
to macro, it was right,
and so, I just always think long-term,
because I don't need anything short-term.
And that's it, so like, you
need to start making decisions
on, you know, how you think
about those two things.
It's just legacy and currency.
It's just money, and how you feel.
And everybody gives up how
they feel for short term money
and then they try to reconstruct it later.
Problem is, everything's on the record.
- Yeah.
- We know Jay-Z did a
Budweiser commercial.
That's it.
So that's it, man, and I
think the key for me, is
I've never wavered.
From when nobody knew who I was,
to a lot more people
now who know who I am,
just the same shit, every day, for ever.
And I know, forever.
I love when people are like, oh,
especially my closest friends
and everybody now, like
"Man, it's getting so weird,
I hope you don't change,"
I'm like, you haven't figured
out what I'm doing here.
So I think that's super simple,
you just gotta figure out
you just gotta build
yourself, now, by the way
some people want a car,
some people want to put their
mom in a penthouse, like
you're you, but understand this,
every time you pick the money,
you're taking a couple of
petals out of the legacy place.
- Right.
- The end.
- But how do you reconcile
that with short term needs,
like you said,
- I get it.
By understanding the score.
Just understanding the score,
just knowing that truth.
I've taken it, I bought an
apartment on the Upper East Side
which made me less liquid,
which didn't allow me to put
as much money into Facebook
and Uber, and Twitter,
and I lost hundreds of millions of dollars
because I needed a million
dollars for an apartment,
that was a mistake.
Right?
Like, right now, I really want
to help my family business
so I'm pushing wine on my social media,
and I'm throwing right
hooks, that's taking away,
because, for the last 18
months I've had the luxury
of just giving at scale.
Just knowing the score, right?
I feel great about helping
out my dad's business.
At the expense of me
losing people's attention
because they don't wanna hear about wine.
I'm cool with that.
- But you can afford that,
not everybody can afford that, right?
- I don't think so, like,
I think I can't afford it,
I'm fuckin' pissed about
giving up leverage.
Do you understand?
It's binary, I can afford it
if you decide that I have dollars,
but that's not what I'm trading for,
shit's not even benefiting me,
so it's double fucking annoying, you know?
It'd be one thing if it was,
like, you know what I mean?
So you're either giving or you're taking.
There's no between,
and I just try to give
as much as possible,
that's why, I know a lot of
people in this community,
I know people are gonna watch us right now
and everybody's yelling
at me, like "You're giving
"the same advice, of putting out music,
"too much music," I'm
like, you don't get it
like, putting out a song is
giving, it's fuckin' free.
This isn't how I grew up
and you're putting out a fuckin' tape,
double sided, two songs, and you want $4,
it's out of the back of your trunk,
this is you uploading shit
to a streaming service
that everybody's getting for fuckin' free,
I mean, macro, $9, whatever, but free.
And you're giving me
three minutes of escapism
and you may say something that
inspires me to do something
and it may benefit you because
you might be that one song away,
just like Logic finally had his song,
puts him in a totally different place.
So, giving, that's what I do,
I put out a song for free every day,
it's called fuckin' DailyVee.
(laughing)
Like, I don't have the
same skills you have,
I have my own version,
and it costs nothing.
So when people are like, "Oh, Gary, but
"you don't know the music
business," I'm like,
I know the attention business,
which trumps everything
and I'm doing my, I'm
eating my own dogfood.
I'm getting high on my supply.
I'm doing what I'm telling people to do.
I'm putting shit out every
day, music every day.
I believe in it the most.
I will be proven to be right in 15 years,
when everyone's like, "Fuck,
it was music every day."
The problem is,
are you good enough to
put out music every day?
Like, plenty of people
could be vlogging every day,
nobody gives a fuck
because they were worth
three fuckin' days.
But if you think you're work fuckin'
365 days a year of songs,
I would highly recommend
that you and your crew
here, think long and hard
of how to do that in a strategic way.
Now, you may say I have
81 songs a year, or 6,
that's on you.
But I would tell you as an artist,
the number one advice I have for you,
and every single artist watching,
is, figure out how many
songs a year you have in you.
Because once you figure that out,
then you put your strategy around that,
and then you fuckin' win.
Because if you're like, "Look, I got
"eight songs a year in
me, eight fuckin' songs!"
and everybody's gonna
figure out how many bangers
versus volume, I understand
what everyone's debating.
If it's eight, well then go
sign a fuckin' record deal
and then make the most
money you can on eight.
But if you've got 96 in
you, you better just fuckin'
build attention at scale,
and build the leverage.
- 96 makes a lot of stupid bars.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Because that's what I'm doing.
The reason not everybody
can do what I'm doing
in the business, everybody wants to,
is they don't have as much
content I them as I do.
- Yeah, right.
- Got it?
That's the 2.0 of what
I've been trying to say,
I'm glad I finally said it,
which is gonna be good for you
because a lot more people
are gonna watch this,
(laughing)
now that I finally got off
what I've been trying to say.
That would be the number one
strategy, first, you know?
People overthink projects,
signing, not signing,
number one binary, if you're an artist,
how many great songs, good songs, songs,
can I put out a year?
And do I have the energy for it?
And how do I do it?
And can I afford it, and am
I in it, and how do I do it?
But, that would be the
biggest piece of advice,
and then the first part
of this meeting, man
legacy, currency.
When you ask, you're giving up leverage,
when you're giving,
you're gaining leverage
and balancing that with your
audience, is everything.
It's why I'm loved,
because I'm fucking, giving
more than I'm taking.
- Right.
I think that's also just your story.
- Even, 100%, because we're
used to not having anything,
my kids have no shot,
they're used to having stuff.
They're used to having stuff,
so the thought of not, like
to me, people don't get
it, I can go back to zero,
I'm like Rocky in that
sixth movie, like, I'm good.
I'll go right back to fuckin' Rego Park
live in a studio
apartment, go to Waldbaums
and be good, dreaming up
how I'm gonna come back
and fuckin', rise like a phoenix, right?
And be like, and read every
fucking comment of like
"I knew Gary V. Was a
fraud, I knew he sucked,
"I knew he'd fall one day,"
and just fuckin' eat that shit
to motivate myself to get
back up, and come back
and be like, I fuckin' told you, so like,
to me, it's equally as
interesting to go back to zero
as it is to go to fuckin' hero,
and that means you're unbeatable,
and that's why immigrants win,
because once you taste it,
you don't wanna go back,
because you're like, fuck
that sucked, this is better,
but you're not completely petrified of it
because you've been there, done that.
- [Kaz] And you know how to get back,
if not with better tools at your disposal.
- 100%, I've done it
once, I can do it again.
Which then allows you to take the risks,
which then allows you to give,
because when you suck, you're taking.
- Yeah.
- [Boyd] Yeah and one thing to quickly
add some context, I was
hanging around with Gary
I was talking about, like, if
you have eight songs a year
and you make your plan
around it, another thing
well, one thing Gary
always says, and I know
you watch a lot of Gary's stuff, so like,
when Gary talks about,
like, attention stuff,
he just told, A-Boogie
for example, like you know
if there's a song, and it's not taking off
and you want it to get hotter, like
why don't you go to the
Bronx, or why don't just
tell your fans to meet you
somewhere, or your case,
like, go somewhere in Queens, or something
and like, create this content
because, like, if you do,
because one thing for you to know, Gary,
because, I was talking to Anik,
and unlike a lot of you guys in Atlanta,
who just, like live in the studio
he was telling me that he kind of just
goes in the studio for
like, two weeks at a time,
and it's like crunch
time, or not crunch time,
but when he's inspired to
like, create a project,
- I get it.
- [Boyd] Given that
knowledge, it's almost like
if you just create a lot of video content
and all that other stuff,
as long as you're keeping
people's attention,
it could still work, you know
like, whatever number of
songs you come out with,
- Boyd, seeing A-Boogie do
that pop up the other day
made me smile cheek to cheek.
- Yeah, that was insane,
that really worked for him.
- No shit!
Because I'm right about this stuff!
Because if you give, you get!
- When I saw that, I
actually, when we went to LA,
it really was like my first
time, because I stayed
for like, a while, like for six days,
and I didn't know,
like, I knew I had fans,
but the show was already sold
out before I got in the door
like, and so, I said we should
just pop up for my merch
and we just picked the
place, it was like yo,
and attire, shit, I couldn't stop moving.
- I get it man, it's
the best feeling ever.
- Doing that, I feel like, and
I've heard you say it before
that's the most important part
- 100%
- Talking to them, personally
and giving them something
personally, to have, they talk about that.
- Depth.
- All, everywhere.
That shit spreads.
- Everybody wants width.
Everybody wants a million
followers, but I'll take 1,000
if every one of them does
what I want them to do,
and gets what they want out of it.
- Yeah.
- It's 100%, and engagement
isn't likes, or shares
engagement's going to shows,
or wearing a menu on your shirt
or taking their time to
tell their friends, like
"You need to listen to
this person's stuff!"
- Yeah, that's the goal.
- I think you need to give,
now that Boyd just put that
context, of the studio,
I'm telling you right now brother,
please think about how
many songs you have in you.
And it may not come easy,
you've maybe never thought of it
like, you need to go inside
yourself and figure that out.
- Right.
- Once you have that figured out,
I'm telling you, that's the new blueprint.
- Okay.
- Once you understand that, then you can,
because there's a lot of,
everybody's doing the same shit
everybody put out fuckin'
albums, then everybody put out
45s, back in the day, then
everybody put out albums
now everybody's putting
out music on the internet,
mixtapes, "projects", right?
(laughing)
I'm like, look, if you
have 150 songs in you,
not everyone can be in your next project,
then take 13 of them,
and give them to the
biggest bloggers on YouTube.
Be like, "Yo, I made this for
you, Paul Brothers, here!"
Like, that's your ammo!
And overthinking the
distribution to fit the box
that everybody's doing,
is the way not to do it.
Like, somebody here needs to email
every video game company, and be like,
we have a great artist, we
have real fuckin' beats,
fire, like, we'll give em' to you,
just put em' in the pre-role of the game,
or anywhere else people's attention is.
Hit up a fuckin' college
that has a big radio station
and be like, "Duke University,
we're giving this to you."
Like, opening lines, "Yo, Duke, what up?"
Go, you!
Because you have that song in you!
And what are you gonna
sit and scrutinize it,
and cut it from the project
at the end, so what?
It's gonna sit in fuckin',
somebody's harddrive?
- Right.
- The fuck?
- Yeah.
- Execution.
- Right.
- Take every fuckin', back
to legacy vs currency.
I build Wine Library into
big business, because
when I built it from a three,
I'm looking at the plaque
with me and my dad, because when it went
from three to 45, it went
up three to 45, because
much like every other
liquor store in New Jersey
owned by Indian families, who were all my,
- You're from Princeton, right?
- Dude, my relationship with
the Indian community is crazy.
Edison, New Jersey, literally in 1986,
is where everybody came, Iselin and Edison
my dad owns the only building in Iselin
not owned by an Indian-American.
(laughing)
The only one.
- He recorded the project in Edison
- First of all, I didn't
know Indian people
lived in Edison, so
- Oh dude, it's crazy.
You must have been like, what?
- Like, what the fuck is going on?
- Dude, it's India, when
you get in there, really.
- I got through miles of Indian
businesses, and I was like
this is like Utopia of India.
- Did I leave a phone in here?
- Is this you?
- Yeah that's me.
(laughing)
- So, you know, I'm the "immigrant"
in Edison, New Jersey,
from '82 to '86, in Edison
because I'm "the Russian kid",
and then one summer goes by
and we go into fifth
grade, '82, '3, '4, '5,
in 1986, four new kids in my
class have the last name Patel
seven of them are from
India, and I'm pumped
because I'm like, okay
good, new immigrants, right?
What I didn't know is that
they were really gonna be my homies,
cause' these kids were like
me, they were here to fuckin'
sell shit, flip baseball
cards, make money, like, grind
so, it went from, first I like it cause'
I wasn't gonna be the only odd-man out,
then I was like, wait a
minute, these are my homies,
so then, that's my first chapter,
then I go into the
liquor business in 1998.
From 1992 to 2015, all of
New Jersey's liquor stores,
80% of them were bought by
Indian-American immigrants.
The whole industry is owned,
because they're hustlers
and they made their thing.
Cool, all that's cool, now
I'm there, then I go into tech
(laughing)
and start meeting all these
developers, and they're
all like, "So, yeah,"
I've always had, like, I've
always had a pretty amazing
relationship with the community,
because I'm built like
that community, and listen
I think a lot about the hip hop,
African-American communities,
it's just the same shit
which is, when you don't have anything,
and you're willing to work.
- Yeah man.
- The way you leverage it, is first of all
you don't have to do anything,
because the truth always
wins, you're part of it.
It's naturally gonna come to you.
You wanna speed it up,
there's a very easy way.
It's called Facebook.
(murmuring agreement)
- I think that's my biggest
gift, even though like,
whilst I was going through
it, I didn't think so, like
even though, like, I
would say I'm an immigrant
but even more than that,
I grew up in lower income apartments,
so I wasn't around Bengalese, right?
I was around African-Americans,
and Hispanics,
- That's how you ended up here.
- Right, because I
understand the perspective
of what they're coming
from, but I also still
know my heritage, and what I'm doing,
and it's just that balance of both.
- It's such a home run.
I wish I'd never left Queens, I mean it.
- You could come back, man.
(laughing)
- You know what's crazy, I got real lucky
we moved to, basically, a
very lower-middle class, white
neighborhood, for my highschool,
like, it's crazy, like
I'd never been around
wealth my whole life.
It's the best thing that
ever happened to me.
- Yeah, people ask me, "Why
you so close to your family?"
I say, cause' I never had shit.
- I get it.
- All we have is each other.
- 100%, man, I'm the same way, I get it.
Tell your true stories,
man, they're universal.
It's not Indian, or Russian,
or black, it's universal.
These stories are universal.
It's just the same stories
with a different coat of paint.
- Yeah, man.
- There's only two stories,
the haves, and the have-nots
(mouth clicking)
That's it.
You gotta figure out how much
music you have in you, man.
That's the best piece of
advice I can give you.
- Okay.
- That will help you.
Because, if you, and I don't know
maybe, you know, like, again
- I'm definitely not the 65 songs,
and I know that about myself.
- You know what, that's great.
Even though my vibes go
towards the 365 songs,
like, if it's fuckin' 16,
you could be smart then.
That gets into your team
gettin' together, like
honestly, even just this
team, I think that's helpful
I don't know how much
pressure you guys have put
on this conversation, but if I know
that you're saying it's 12,
you guys need to take a
real step back, and be like,
okay, we need to strategize
around projects in a different,
if you can launch four projects
a year, or once a week songs
versus having one project a year,
you have a totally
different fuckin' 365 days.
- Yeah, that's what we just actually,
I don't know if you heard
of an Indian streaming company, Saavn?
- I'm sorry?
- The Indian streaming
service company, Saavn.
- I'm aware.
- So, because we, you now, I know that
I don't make music like that,
I still wanna push Kites
and the project, we're
partnering with them
to figure out more video
content, and more things.
- 100%.
- Like, do them together.
- Do you write?
- Yeah.
- How often?
- Write it down?
- Yeah, like how do you do,
do you write your music?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I write all my music.
- Good, how do you write?
- Like, when I'm driving,
- So, it's there, and
then you just go improv?
- And I go into the studio,
- Spit it from the dome?
- Well, I'll write in the studio as well,
just in my head, where I'm like,
- I still think nobody's figured out,
I think somebody needs to be documenting
the entire writing process.
- Oh right, wow, that'd be really cool.
- If I could see how the 15
songs that I love the most
origin stories, why do
you think comic books win?
Comic books win because
we know Spider Man got bit
by a fuckin', spider,
like, we're like, oh shit!
Origin stories, I think,
are a missing thing.
Like, if I was like, oh
my god, my favorite hook
that you ever came up with, was because
you tripped, like going to Burger King,
and you're like "Damn,
skinned knees, skinned knees"
like, look, I don't know!
- We talk about that all the time.
- Well generally, because they
don't really talk about that
because, we have all
these great content ideas,
but then I feel that,
because this media industry
is so consumed by content, that
they want to make their own
I think that sometimes
we're debilitated because
we have to wait until someone
says, like, okay, cool
we'll do that, rather
than just putting it out
- Yeah, I get the complex, I get it,
but I didn't wait for Wall Street Journal,
or Fortune, or Forbes to put me on.
You have something called YouTube,
and Facebook, and Instagram, and SnapChat,
you just need, right now,
the fact that you have fans,
somebody will work for free, to be Tyler,
follow you around with a
camera, he's 17 years old,
he loves your music the most in the world,
he's got nothing else going on,
and he's gonna follow you around for free,
and that's that.
(laughing)
- We're literally interviewing
him in three hours.
- That's it, that's the game.
- I got something for you, man
- Please.
- Let me actually get it now.
So, these are the different colors.
- I can't wait to listen, man, thank you.
I love it, I'm gonna rock em'.
You know what, though, cause'
I'm really gonna rock em',
can somebody send me mediums,
because I won't wear these largest,
- Oh, no, they're slim fit,
- Tight?
- Yeah.
- Got it, great, then
I will 100% rock em'.
- They'll fit better at large,
and you'll be hugged up.
- Perfect, got it, perfect.
I love it, I need to run,
because I got my dad's charity wine event,
- Absolutely.
But I'd love to take some photos.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Put you on a little bit.
- That'd be awesome, man.
- What's going on on your
Instagram, how's it going?
What is your Instagram, let me follow you.
- AnikKhan_,
A N I K K H A N,
- It's one word?
- Yep, underscore at the end.
- I see it, love it.
Followed.
You need to post way more often.
- Thank you!
(laughing)
- Look, I'm on the thing every day.
- Time to go.
- Every day, my phone's just broke.
Every day.
- Okay.
- Every day.
The biggest thing, I'm gonna tell you,
I can feel it already, if
you're precious, you'll lose.
- Right, damn, okay.
- Dude, I told you,
the first time we ever met about music.
- Imma' fight you when we get outside.
(laughing)
- You know what I mean?
I get it, but I'm telling
you with all my heart.
I want you to win, if
you're precious you'll lose.
- Okay.
- The amount of real
talents that are losing
out of preciousness, and then it's over.
- Right.
(emotional electronic music)